and the former children's commissioner
for england and longfield who's the
chair of the commission on young lives
joins me now thank you so much for
talking to us this morning
so you believe the system is
unsustainable morally and economically
for teenagers that are at risk i
absolutely do and you heard there um how
a system that's designed to protect
children is woefully inadequate when it
gets to protecting teenagers now these
are teenagers who are being often
exploited they're at extreme risk
they're being tracked down and groomed
by very agile ruthless exploiters um
there isn't enough um
mechanism there aren't enough mechanisms
in place to identify them in the first
place the coordination isn't there to
keep them safe there aren't the kind of
rings of protection there to be able to
keep those children at home safely with
their parents and when they do come into
care because there's such a chronic
shortage of accommodation for children
of this age they're moved around the
country they're moved very frequently
all of the things which kind of destroys
the relationships that they need to be
able to be protected
and most disastrously they're often
placed in unregulated accommodation
which can be dangerous and which is
often targeted by the exploiters
themselves
reading a brief that i have of your
report and listening to what you say
it's hard to even
imagine where you would start
correcting this
well i think you start by understanding
how these young people are experiencing
um their childhood essentially
they need relationships they need
protection
they need help as early as possible what
you've got is a care system that
essentially was designed around very
young children but the big increase over
recent years has been around older
children and teenagers now a core to all
those kids in care are 16 and 17 year
olds so we need a new package around
that group of children now i want to see
more kept at home more protected and
before crisis hits but that means really
intensive help that isn't there at the
moment but also if they do come into
care they're much more creative suitable
ways of looking after them i'd like for
instance to see um you know new
specialist foster carers let's look at
youth workers and see how many of those
could provide that stable supportive
foster care home that these young people
need i think we just need to look at a
package here which can really help and
understand these children and whilst it
will require some money in the short
term we're spending eye watering amounts
here already on the um care support that
is in place it's often that children
these children's places are costing 4
000 pounds a week now the alternatives
would be much better for children but
also much more cost effective as well i
just want to pick up on one of your
findings in the report that you've
spoken about and that is that criminal
gangs who are looking to exploit
children within the system are being
aided by people who are working in the
system
well that's something that a number of
people who've given evidence to us has
said clearly you know the care system is
full of
excellent people who are doing their
utmost for very good reasons um to help
the most vulnerable children but it does
seem that there is on some there are in
some occasions individuals around
possibly local authorities who are doing
this we also heard from some police
forces that actually they feared that
some of the unregulated provision was
actually being run by organized crime
again something which will put these
teenagers at immense risk so it has to
be a priority there is an independent
review of children's social care going
on we would like teenagers and the
reform of support for dna should be very
high on the list and we'd like
government to be already working on how
they're going to address these issues
and do you think that's going to happen
well i think it has to happen the
children's social care review has
already highlighted how confused and
stretched the system is around teenagers
so it's important that has been
recognized now we need to look at
solutions which is what the commission
that i chair is all about government i
think has to recognize what is going
wrong but also its role in putting it
right that has to be an urgent priority
anne longfield thank you so much for
talking to us